So one way of doing this is,
just compare that distribution
to the distributions of the word,
of the, of the images that you know.
And you can do it as say,
like a, a scaler.product, right?
So just a histogram.
If you normalize it to one, you can
think of it as a normalized vector, and
I can pair, unit vector,
I can compare unit vectors, for example,
by taking dot product and
finding nearest neighbor.
So, that's illustrated here.
So I have some exampled,
d sub j and I want to,
I've got some query, q, and
I want to compare them.
And so, here are my two histograms.
So my histogram here is 1, 8, 1, 4.
My histogram over here is 5, 1, 1, 0.
So remember,
it's the same set of words, right?
We're just going to say for all the
words in English, what's the histogram?
For all the words in my collection,
what's the histogram?
And I'm just going to compare,
say a similarity.
So here is one example of where I take
the dot product between the d and
q, divide by the length and
that's essentially giving me
a similarity between them.
And this is just written out for
i equal 1 to v,
where the idea is that you
have v number of words.
And again, we didn't talk about exactly
how you decide if what v should be.
That's sort of part of
the art of doing this work.
So that's essentially doing
a nearest neighbor look up, right?
Given some input,
nearest neighbor, all right?